Howdy Folks my last video got a lot more
attention than I was anticipating and I
have a couple of non-magic gathering
videos that I'm currently doing research
for so I figured I may as well put out a
short little video with a few more
thoughts on the EDH format
today I'm going to be talking about a
couple different ways of orienting a
deck in relation to its commander and
one in particular that I find to be
underrated
to start with let's talk about a pretty
conventional way of constructing a
commander deck
you find a commander that looks cool you
find cards that synergize well with said
commander and then you fill in the gaps
with other things the deck needs to
succeed
this is a simple and malleable format
but there are other options out there
to talk about those a useful exercise is
to think about the rules of the
commander format as if you've never seen
them before
you're building a 99 card Singleton deck
something with a naturally High degree
of variability
but you have an ace up your sleeve a
card that you will always have every
single game
you could make that card cranko mob boss
and then play a Goblin's deck
and that's a perfectly valid plan
but something you might notice about
that plan is that the Commander in the
deck do basically the same thing
play goblins
a lot of strong decks will opt to have
the commander do something tangential to
the rest of the deck tying in with some
key cards but broadly offering something
different in nature than the rest of the
deck
however my favorite form of this
relationship is where the commander does
the exact opposite of the thing that the
rest of the deck is trying to do
basically you pick out a commander and
then you build a mid-rangey deck with a
glaring weakness solved by that
Commander
an example that comes to mind is a
glissa sunslayered deck that I built
several months back
the card is a fantastic creature for
three Mana an absurdly effective blocker
a draw engine and a source of endless
sadness for Dex running enchantments
the Eda track page seems to consist
mostly of decks trying to capitalize on
roof encounters from your cards but I
instead opted to build a hardcore battle
cruiser deck
the Commander's flexibility and daunting
presence means that I can fully forget
about early game creatures and not worry
as much about draw instead jamming my
deck to the brim with ramp removal and
massive guards
I have a top-notch blocker that's also a
draw engine every single game and that
lets me use my deck slots to focus on
being the greedy that I truly want
to be deep inside
another example of this is a liaison
deck I built recently
when I first saw liasa I went God that
card could absolutely beat the tar out
of people
all I want in this world is to
mercilessly beat my opponents with that
angel
so great my commander is selected
how to build a deck around it
well judging by the Eda Trek page most
people's answer that question is to put
it in a life game deck
now I don't hate this approach you know
run a bunch of cards that gain life and
some life gain Synergy and a commander
that will sap life out of both you and
your opponents
it makes sense and you could even argue
that it sort of fits my template here
but that's not the direction I went in
instead I decided to build a deck that's
just dying craving for a beater to cut
through a stale board state
I built a hate bear stack
I crammed as many hay pairs as I
possibly could into the deck
just truly an upsetting wall of little
guys trying to ruin the day of
my poor opponents
and the deck has ended up working
exactly as intended in a good portion of
games
the cards in the deck chip and damage
prevent damage coming at me and
generally hinder my opponents in all
sorts of ways
and then liaisa cuts through the
resulting board Quagmire to reduce my
opponents to a paste like homogeneous
by Design it's a deck with roughly a
liaison shaped hole and I'm able to play
liaison for five Mana anytime I want in
any game I want
there's a lot of room for variation here
but this gives a decent idea of the
basic formula
running a commander that covers a
particular element of the deck allows a
player to build a deck that puts that
element on the back burner instead
focusing all its effort on the things it
knows it can succeed at
this way you can effectively just solve
the problem that you know your deck will
have ahead of time instead of agonizing
over how many deck slots to devote to it
I certainly don't like the prospect of
figuring out how to kill my opponents
consistently with a low to mid-budget
hate Bears deck so I just avoided that
question
mid-range is often something that people
look down on for being boring or Bland
but with some creative usage of the
rules of the format you can build a
really fun deck that exists within the
mid-range Realm
and I think more people should give that
a try